you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is game 2
from the 2013 World Chess Championship
match between Anandi Carlsen going into
this round both players had half a point
each and Anand on the white end and this
one opened with e4 Carlsen replied with
the very solid
caro-kann defense c6 and we go down a
mainline variation with Bishop f5 and h4
to follow looking to trap the bishop and
or grab some space one of those two is
prevented the bishop will no longer be
trapped but white could grab some space
with h5 later and so one question might
be well why not prevent both by playing
h5 yourself I'll keep in mind g5 is now
available for the white minor pieces and
your H pawn is more accessible by the
white pieces so it's just a single step
with h6
9 f3 looking to post-up in the center
with tempo on the bishop this is allowed
a 6 is played Knight d7 would rule that
out altogether and well however you look
at it this Bishop on g6 will be attacked
in some way sometimes it's with the
knight centralizing itself and other
times it'll be with h5 grabbing some
King side space with an attack on the
bishop so he will be the bishop on g6
will be hit with either the knight or
the white H pawn and in this game it's
hit with the knight Knight to e5 drops
back in short order he will be
challenged but first we have the offer
of a light square bishop exchange and
for this one moment it looks like d4 can
be captured but that is not so due to
this tactical shot on f7 we're at the
end of it white picks up the black Queen
and just slightly a slight tweak of that
variation after this capture if black
throws in a check we don't move our King
because this would allow this sort of
exchange and at the end of it black is
this side who's winning but we would
reply by playing c3 hitting the bishop
not attacking the Queen just yet due to
the pin but we will be attacking the
Queen after Bishop takes Bishop and now
Bishop d2 now this is back on the bishop
is sit the queen is hit and so too is
the rook after the Queen moves Knight
takes rook White is the better side so
in short we don't take the pawn on d4
due to the tactical shot and they takes
f7 bishops come off and now we challenge
the one piece in our position 97 f4 is
there to reinforce the strong Knight and
this is a very important detail as
otherwise you could be in for a very
long road ahead if you're going with
routine like moves of castle we have
this sort of stuff going on not only
might there be Queen takes pawn come to
think of it but just looking from a
structural point of view this is
terrible backward pod on a half-open
file don't go down that road you're
you're gonna get tortured not a good
idea so that's why we have f4 to support
the knight
now comes first check on b4 and only
then dropping back to e7 so what exactly
was accomplished with those last two
moves
well how we can figure that out is by
looking at this pond what was what was
provoked c3 well what are the
differences behind having the pawn on c3
opposed to c2
well since it's no longer around on its
home square this Queen is maybe a bit
more tactically vulnerable in some lines
that I will highlight in a little bit
but first more development on the white
side playing 2d - instead of III I
believe so that it's not as accessible
to let's say a black knight so just
clearing the way for Queen side
development which is certainly the safer
of the two homes for the white King if
you're going to play f4 and h4 you've
weakened g4 you are making your H pawn
accessible not the safe way to go not
the safe home for the white King so
Knight to f6
it's queenside castle and King sight
castle for Black Knight e4 and well why
is this played and he's not so great
on the g3 square that's one thing and
the other is that now this Jeep on can
be set into motion like white would love
to get upon up to the g5 Square where it
would hit to pieces and ensure some
break against the black king position
tonight's one pair of Knights is
exchanged and so too is another now let
me just point out one variation where it
shows that this Queen could be
tactically vulnerable you'll note that
if white is looking to open up the
position in some way on the Kings side
with let's say this f5 pawn break this
is terrible of course this Queen even if
she still were protected I'm not so sure
that this would be a good idea for white
to be playing this f5 move because we
would yet again have an instance where
white would have a backward pun on a
half-open file but the other one is to
recognize that we don't go down that
road where we lose a piece but what if
we say first
okay let's capture on d7 and then hit at
the black position with this pawn break
f5
well you'll note that 'if I've is
available exploiting this pin if pawn
takes pawn we're losing the Queen but if
you can envision the pawns still on c2
this turns out to actually be a bad
reply by black II five would not be good
if this pawn were still around on its
home square so just a quick point
addressing this idea of the initial
deployment of the Bishop to b4 and only
then dropping back to e7 so naive four
pair of Knights is exchanged and so too
is the other one with the follow-up of a
queen exchange there's not much choice a
two is hit the queen is hit do you
really want to drop back to b1 and say
I'm just going to have my queen function
as if it's only a bishop no so what are
your other options well it's either you
exchange Queens or you play to g4 which
says well if you take my opponent e2 I'm
going to take this pawn on h6 this is
the threat with Queen to g4 exploiting
the pin on the
gee file but black would not take on a -
in the follow-up would likely be f5
challenging the Queen if this pun is
captured on percent black is doing quite
well even though this pun is a bit more
vulnerable the black pieces are now
mobilized this rook is here to defend h6
and is now prepared to double on the F
file and this Queen
not to mention is very well placed so in
short we did not have Queen g4 but
rather the Queen's come off the board we
capture now in the most principled
manner towards the center and now h5
locking down in this structure one day
looking for some good Bishop versus bad
bishop situation where he can somehow
get the bishop on d2 could somehow get
it g7 or h6 b5 is the start of minority
attack to break down this strong white
pawn structure with b5 we will see a 5
right away but first a rook lifts by
white looking to yet again yet again put
pressure well not yet again but similar
to how I showed with the Queen playing
to the G file white wants to have that
tactical threat in mind with Bishop
takes h6 so rook h3 is the start of that
a5 is played now in a position to play
b4 rook f1 rook to c8 opposite the king
and now we have rook g3 which is
threatening Bishop takes h6 there's not
very many options King h7 is played rook
f3 this pawn is hit twice
not very many options the King drops
back to g8 what are the alternatives you
move this pawn you are allowing the rook
to sneak into the black position and put
pressure on a base point and I'm not so
sure that you really want to do that as
black you know know that you really want
to give up the g6 square so black drops
back with the King that's the only other
way to defend against f7 and similar to
game 1 we end up with a repetition of
position
this is a war really each game is a
battle and there will be draws involved
this one is yet another it finished
about an hour and five minutes and round
one finished in an hour and a half
what will we have in store for around
3:00 tomorrow is a rest day and then we
will resume at the same time as it
stands right now we have two games
played two draws one point each for
Anand and Carlsen and we will look
forward to round three and see what
happens there so that's all for this
video as always I hope you got something
out of it take care bye
you